SO-CALLED VISUAL ALBUM.
>> BEYONCE COMMANDS ATTENTION
LIKE FEW OTHER ARTISTS ON THE
PLANET.
THIS MOST RECENT ALBUM, NUMBER
SIX FOR HER, SHOWS EXACTLY WHY
THAT IS.
ITS TITLE IS "LEMONADE."
MAKES YOU THINK OF SOMETHING
SWEET AND SUGARY.
THIS IS ACTUALLY A DARK ALBUM OF
DEEPLY PERSONAL LYRICS,
SOMETIMES VERY RAW, AS BEYONCE
TALKS ABOUT LOVE AND MARRIAGE,
FEMINISM AND RACIAL IDENTITY.
HER FANS ARE BUZZING ABOUT THIS.
THEY HAVE BEEN SINCE THE MOMENT
HER MOVIE WAS RELEASED ON HBO ON
SATURDAY NIGHT.
THEN THE ACCOMPANYING ALBUM WAS
STREAMED ONLINE.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST TALKING
POINTS IS ABOUT THE HINTS OF
INFI
INFIDELITY.
YOU LOOK AT THE LYRICS IT'S
PRETTY CLEAR WHAT SHE'S TALKING
ABOUT.
SHE'S ADDRESSING THE
LONGSTANDING RUMORS ABOUT HER
MARRIAGE TO JAY-Z.
THE RUMORS THAT AT TIMES HE HAS
PERHAPS BEEN WITH OTHER WOMEN.
WHAT'S SO INTERESTING HERE IS
THAT SHE'S ADDRESSING IT
PUBLICLY.
SHE'S TAKING IT HEAD-ON, KNOWING
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN GOSSIPING ABOUT
HER FOR A LONG TIME.
AT 1 POINT IN THE INDIVIDUAL
SORROW YOU SEE HER WALKING DOWN
THE STREET SWINGING A BAT.
BUT BY THE END EVER THE MOVIE
YOU DO SEE HER WITH HER FAMILY,
JAY-Z AND THEIR DAUGHTER
APPEARING HAPPY TOGETHER.
IT HAS A LOT OF FANS BUZZING.
IN FACT, WE'VE SEEN SOME
RESPONSES ONLINE.
I CAN SHOW YOU ONE OF THEM FROM
ONE EVER THE WOMEN THAT'S COME
UP OVER THE YEARS.
THIS WOMAN NAMED RACHEL ROY, A
FASHION DESIGNER.
SHE'S BEEN LINKED TO JAY-Z IN
THE PAST BUT JUST RUMORS.
HERE IS WHAT SHE WROTE ON
TWITTER TODAY.
SHE SAID, I RESPECT LOVE,
MARRIAGES, FAMILY AND STRENGTH.
WHAT SHOULDN'T BE TOLERATED BY
ANYONE NO MATTER WHAT IS
BULLYING OF ANY KIND.
THAT SEEMS TO ME TO BE A
RESPONSE FROM HER TO BEYONCE AND
TO THESE SONGS.
WE'LL SEE IF BEYONCE GETS INTO A
BACK-AND-FORTH OR NOT.
FOR NOW, IT'S INTERESTING TO SEE
HOW BEYONCE IS RELEASING THIS
NEW ALBUM.
BACK DURING THE SUPER BOWL IN
FEBRUARY SHE LAUNCHED ONE OF THE
SONGS "FORMATION" AS SORT OF A
PREVIEW OF HER ALBUM.
THEN SHE REALIZED AN HOUR-LONG
RELEASE FOR HBO ON SATURDAY,
THEN PUT THE ENTIRE ALBUM ONLINE
ON THE ARTIST-OWNED STREAMING
SERVICE CALLED TITLE.
NOW TITLE IS SUPPORTED, BANK
ROLLED BY JAY-Z AND OTHER
ARTISTS.
IF FACT, PRINCE WHO JUST DIED
WAS ALSO A SUPPORTER OF TITLE.
HE PUT MANY OF HIS ALBUMS THERE.
IN ORDER TO LISTEN TO THE NEW
ALBUM FOR NOW, YOU HAVE TO GO TO
TITLE.
IT'S A BIG WEEK FOR THE SERVICE
PROMOTING A FREE TRIAL FOR
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO CHECK IT OUT.
IN THE WEEKS AND MONTHS TO COME,
SHE WILL LIKELY MAKE IT
AVAILABLE IN OTHER WAYS AS WELL
AS PEOPLE CAN BUY IT OR STREAM
IT ON OTHER SITES.
FOR NOW, IT'S INTERESTING TO SEE
HOW BEYONCE IS AS ALWAYS
CONTROLLING HER MESSAGE AND
CONTROLLING HER DISTRIBUTION.
SHE HAS A LOT T